yeah he sort of visit of the founding
father of physics basically so in you
can't really get much bigger deal than
that for a physicist Iran astronomer he
really was the man who invented the
whole subject is a big deal because he's
the first person to actually use
mathematics and develop mathematics so
that you could create a theory work out
the consequences and compare with
experiment so for example his three laws
can be expressed mathematically turned
into equations and then you find out
that the planets go round in ellipses
with the Sun at one of the focuses foci
of the ellipse Sir Isaac Newton is
thought to be one of the greatest
scientists of all time has contributed a
lot to the field he developed calculus
he invented a reflecting telescope that
was made from a mirror instead of a lens
he's oh he's sometimes credited with
having invented the reflecting telescope
which isn't true in fact lots of people
have sort of played around with him even
Galileo the first person who used one
astronomical tree had actually played
around trying to make telescopes out of
mirrors but but Newton's great genius is
that he actually built a practical one
one that actually worked what Newton did
was incredible and a lot of the things
that he came up with the basis
understand for example when he was a
student he there were light beams going
through the shutters of his window and
he put it through a prism and showed
that light was split into the spectrum
and as a result of that he could explain
why rainbows came about and he was able
to turn the mathematics and do the
experiments so as to analyze the natural
world in a way nobody had done before
but he was a bit of a strange character
he wasn't an extroverts he didn't really
get along with people very well I've
read that he had a couple of nervous
breakdowns he was a very very sensitive
person so when the calculus his
mathematics
came up he and Leibnitz both invented
complementary aspects to it and they
didn't he couldn't see that Leibnitz
works on the integral calculus was
complementary to his work all the
differential calculus he just wanted a
rubbish Leibnitz all his life and so it
was a competition and he was very
arrogant and aggressive about things
like that hey also with Robert Hooke who
was a wonderful experimentalist and
wrote the standard treatise on optics he
was an enemy as far as
Newton was concerned and he would try to
do anything to damage hopes reputation
so he wasn't wouldn't being a nice
colleague to have one of the things that
Newton is most famous for is saying that
you know if he's seen further than
anybody else it was only because he was
standing on the shoulders of giants and
this was always viewed as a kind of
self-deprecating remark that he was
actually you know showing respect to
those who had come before him more
recently it's been suggested actually he
was just having a go at Hooke who was
famously very short and so there are
aspects of him he was a little bit
strange he was not necessarily a
particularly nice man he was incredibly
secretive he would keep stuff hidden
away for years and years just because he
was afraid that other people were going
to steal his ideas but he was a
scientist through and through and he
used himself to experiment with a lot of
different projects so when he was
working with lenses and mirrors and
optics he actually wondered why our eyes
are such sophisticated lenses and so he
actually took an icepick and kind of
probed behind his eye to figure out how
it worked and so well it's kind of gross
I hate that's Isaac Newton's a
fascinating character because he's
famous for writing the Principia
Mathematica which certainly changed the
face of physics but Newton wrote more
about theology and prophecy and alchemy
than he ever did about science and
mathematics and that's extraordinary
thing and Newton had some very very
eccentric theological views views about
Christianity Isaac Newton also liked to
look at the Sun to see how that affected
your eyes so of course as children we
all here don't look at the Sun too long
because it go blind well he did actually
look at the Sun for quite a long time
and then he remarked in his journal that
he saw the image of the Sun and his eye
while he was sleepy Riley was going to
sleep even for about three days so it's
definitely does damage to your eye I
believe it but Newton also rejected the
traditional Christian view that God is
not just an individual but God is a
community of Father Son and Holy Spirit
and we call that the Trinity three
persons in one God
and Newton rejected the the view of the
church that God is Trinity it's ironic
because Newton was a fellow of Trinity
College Cambridge so in his very working
environment the institution that he
worked for was dedicated to a doctrine a
teaching in which he himself did not
believe well when I first came to
Nottingham I live way out in
Lincolnshire and somebody told us that
his house that was at Walsall near
coastal Worth and we drove out there and
I got the wrong wool sock there too out
there eventually we found the right one
and there in those days is over 30 years
ago it was the house was owned by
somebody and and you had to go out a
certain time and she'd open the door for
you he didn't go around and see all the
traces he'd left behind because he got
his compasses and scratched pictures of
the cathedral in Grantham on the wall so
I remember that vividly gradually this
aura came to settle around Newton that
he was the holder of secrets and that
the Principia was as it were this was
Newton's scripture and Newton himself
fostered this this reputation for being
some sort of prophet of God and he did
right under some pseudonyms one of which
was the pseudonym Jehovah Sanctus Eunice
Jehovah the name of God the holy one
which he believed was an anagram of the
Latin version of his own name Isaac asst
newtonís Jehovah's sanctus Eunice I
thought a manor house would be a biggie
Elizabethan manor but it's actually a
small pokey little place it's not much
bigger than ordinary semi only on one
floor or maybe two floors it wasn't that
grand
I mean think of The Da Vinci Code today
and Dan Brown I mean there's nothing new
in all that is this is there something
we're not being told it's a bit like a
conspiracy theory and can we get
underneath it all and just as Newton
thought that he was trying to
decode the universe the mind of God by
this mathematics so he thought that
there were all other coats all over the
place including his own name and
anagrams that needed decoding to see
what they revealed so knowledge had to
be prized prized door opened to get the
secrets and only the very clever only
only the wise could really find out
exactly what was going on in the mind of
God he was he had that all the trappings
of a genius in the sense that as well as
being credibly small or coming up with
incredibly innovative ideas he also
clearly had his eccentricities as well
would you give him a job here I thought
hmm that's a good question oh no how he
would succeed in in academia today I
don't know is that your answer a lot of
the things that you know these
eccentricities the the way he tended to
rub people up the wrong way the fact
that he didn't publish things he hidden
them away for years at a time you know
in in academia today the way to succeed
is by getting your ideas out there and
by publishing things and showing you
know showing you all your peers your
fellow scientists what you're doing and
his approach to science of keeping stuff
very much to himself and not wanting to
share it with people really wouldn't
work terribly well in the way that
science works today he was really quite
phenomenal in its prime and later on he
dabbled in alchemy and all sorts of
things and got into religious arguments
he was a very strange and complicated
person not the sort that you want to get
on the pub with and then you'd start
arguing in your Australian way to sit to
whine about and see what you get out of
it so you can do a video sixty symbols